[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg guten Abend und
willkommen den Blick auf die Handballer
hat nachherr Norbert Lehmann einen
schönen guten Abend auch von mir schauen
wir auf die Themen von heute für eine
whrhafte Demokratie Tag für Tag
demonstrieren tausende gegen
Rechtsextremismus und die AFD jetzt
spricht auch der Bundestag darüber Opfer
rechter nach Eisregen nun Schnee das
Winterwetter sorgt erneut für
kilometerlange Staus auf zahlreichen
Autobahnen und jetzt wird's richtig
ernst im ersten em Hauptrundenspiel
steht der DHB Auswahl mit Island am
Abend ein Härtetest ins
Haus Deutschland steht auf gegen
Rechtsextremismus zur Stunde in Gera und
Mainz gestern Abend z.B in Freiburg
bundesweit sind weitere Demos geplant
Kirchen Gewerkschaften Vereine
Sozialverbände und auch Bundesliga Clubs
rufen zur Teilnahme auf begonnen hat es
in Potzdam vergangenen Samstag nach der
Enthüllung über das Treffen von
Rechtsradikalen dort der bislang größte
Protest vorgestern in Köln mit rund 30
000 Menschen und auch im Bundestag gab
es heute eine Aktuelle Stunde Titel
klare Kante gegen demokratiefeinde und
vertreibungspläne chran
hübscher die AFD nutzt den
Schlagabtausch im Bundestag um die
korrektivrecherchen erneut als
hinterhältige Kampagne abzutun hinter
allem stecke nur die Angst der Ampel vor
der Abwahl da werden selst kleine
private Debattierclubs zu
gemeinfährlichen Geheimtreffen
aufgeblasen wie verzweifelt muss man
sein um auch daraus eine Kampagne gegen
die AFD zu konstruieren wie sie das
heute wieder versuchen kleine prate
Debattierclubs das
korrektivrecherchenetzwerk hat
nachgelegt und einen weiteren afdler
entternt auch Mario Müller Mitarbeiter
eines Bundestagsabgeordneten war bei dem
Geheimtreffen dabei wo die
millionenfache Ausweisung diskutiert
wurde auch deshalb sei es richtig dass
der Verfassungsschutz die AFD als
rechtsextremen Verdachtsfall beobachte
so die Innenministerin so sehr sie auch
abwiegeln wenn es um rechtsextreme
Vernetzung geht Herr Baumann nichts
davon ist harmlos nichts davon ist
bürgerlich und NS davon dürfen wir dlden
meine Damen und Herren nichts davon der
ostdeutsche CDU Abgeordnete amtor stört
sich auch an dem historischen Vergleich
den die AFD gerade immer wieder
missbrauche dann heißt es DDR Methoden
DDR 2.0 das führen sie im Wort ich kann
Ihnen nur sagen es ist eine
geschichtsvergessene Relativierung dass
Sie unseren freiheitlichen Rechtsstaat
vergleichen mit einer staatlich
organisierten massenüberwachung gegen
die es keinen Rechtsschutz gab aus den
Reihen der Grünen hieß es die AFD sei
zwar demokratisch gewählt aber nicht
demokratisch sie verachten unser
demokratisches vielfältiges menschliches
Gesicht sind Faschisten auch außerhalb
des Parlaments geht der Protest weiter
für die Demokratie gegen die AFD so wie
hier am Abend in
Mainz und wie eben auch schon erwähnt
gerade protestieren auch in Gera im
Osten Thüringens der AFD gegen Rassismus
und
Rechtsextremismus nach Polizeiangaben
versammeln sich zur Stunde rund 300
Menschen vor einem Bürgerhaus dort hat
die AFD zu einem Bürgerdialog mit dem
türanger Parteichef höcke eingeladen die
Forderung der Demonstranten ein AFD
Verbot auch die Bauern drohen mit neuen
weitreichenden Protesten ab Montag wenn
die geplanten subventionsstreichungen
beim Agrardiesel nicht zurücken genommen
werden Landwirtschaftsminister östemier
versuchte im Bundestag die Wogen zu
glätten cduf März war auf der Ampel vor
sie regiere gegen die Bevölkerung Britta
spiekemann
berichtet die Proteste der Landwirte
Hallen nach Thema heute im Bundestag
eigentlich der Agrarbericht auf diesen
geht Oppositionschef märz nicht konkret
ein er nutzt die Bühne zur
Generalabrechnung mit der ampelregierung
kommen sie mit ihrer Politik zur
Besinnung bevor im Laufe dieses Jahres
Teile unseres Landes unregierbar werden
März kritisiert scharf dass Kanzler
Scholz und Minister Harbeck nicht
anwesend sind ein Antrag der AFD sie ins
Plenum zu zitieren wird von der
Regierungsmehrheit abgelehnt die Union
enthält sich den Agrarbericht rückt der
Landwirtschaftsminister wieder in den
Fokus östemier bringt erneut den
tierwolcent ins Spiel einen Aufschlag
für Verbraucher auf tierische Produkte
zu Gunsten von Landwirten so wie ihn die
sogenannte beuchardkommission vor Jahren
empfohlen hat wenn die Currywurst ein
paar Cent teurer wird dann ist die
Furcht halt vom schitzturm Gruß aber ich
frag mal woll wir wirklich so
weitermachen immer laut rufen Beuchert
umzusetzen und unsere Tierhalter dann
wenn es drauf ankommt im Regen stehen
lassen alle ampelfraktionen Versprechen
weniger Bürokratie und weniger
Marktmacht des
Einzelhandels und ich bin mir sehr
sicher dass wir im Sommer dann auch für
die Landwirtin und Landwirte zeigen
können dass wir hier ein Gesetzespaket
verabschieden was weitaus mehr ist und
mehr Sicherheit gibt als augenblicklich
der Fall ist Lächeln für die Kameras
heute Abend auf der Grünen Woche die
morgen offiziell eröffnet wird der
Streit um den Agrardiesel bleibt der
bauernpräsident sagt wir wollen
weiterhin die vollen Subventionen die
Regierung will diese schrittweise
abbauen wir gehen wieder auf die Straße
drohen die Landwirte mit weiteren
Protesten schon nächste Woche
vergangene Woche haben sie die
bauernproteste unterstützt jetzt sind
Lkwfahrer aus ganz Deutschland nach
Berlin gekommen um auf die Probleme
ihrer eigenen Branche aufmerksam zu
machen sie fordern von der Politik die
Rücknahme von mauterhöhungen und CO2
Preisen sowie niedrigere Steuern auf
gewerbediesel außerdem verlangen sie
Verbesserung der Infrastruktur unter
anderem mehr
autobahnrastplätze Bundestag beschloss
gerade auch das sogenannte
rückführungsgesetz es soll die
Abschiebung ausreisepflichtiger
Flüchtlinge
erleichtern das Gesetz sieht unter
anderem vor dass Migranten statt 10 nun
28 Tage in Abschiebehaft festgehalten
werden können im vergangenen Jahr wurden
laut Innenministerium rund
16400 Migranten abgeschoben das sind 27%
mehr als im Jahr zuvor Andreas hupert
berichtet
das vorläufige Ende einer Hoffnung die
Hoffnung auf ein besseres Leben
hierzulande abgelehnte Asylbewerber auf
dem Weg zurück in Richtung Heimatland
schneller und mehr abschieben das hatte
der Bundeskanzler angekündigt jetzt hat
sich die ampelregierung auf ein
entsprechendes Gesetz geeinigt die wir
verhindern dass Personen untertauchen
können mit diesem
gesetzgebungspaket bevor sie abgeschoben
werden können wir erleichtern die
Identitätsfeststellung und das wird
dafür sorgen dass wir die Rückführung
auch
tatsächlich nach oben fahren können das
Gesetz verlängert die Abschiebehaft von
10 auf 28 Tage außerdem wird eine
rechtliche Grundlage geschaffen durch
suchungen in Asylunterkünften
auszuweiten auch um Daten und Dokumente
zur Klärung der Identität zu beschaffen
um so eine mögliche Abschiebung
schneller umsetzen zu können das alles
reiche aber nicht aus sagt die CDU
selbst die Bundesregierung geht davon
aus dass man maximal 600 Personen
jährlich zusätzlich durch dieses Gesetz
abschieben kann das bedeutet niemand in
Deutschland auch die Städte und
Gemeinden werden eine Wirksamkeit dieses
Gesetzes spüren geflüchteten
Organisationen schlagen Alarm sehen sehr
wohl eine Verschärfung und zwar eine
unzumutbare ich sehe eine Aufgabe bei
dem Rechtsstaat die Grundrechte von von
diesem Menschen zu schutzen und nicht
die Grundrechte von den zu zu verletzen
nur damit die abschiebezahlen erhurt
würden Grundrechtsverletzungen für die
einen untauglich für konsequente
Abschiebungen sagen die anderen das
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz der
ampelregierung muss jetzt seine
Praxistauglichkeit in Sachen
Abschiebungen unter
Beweisstellen die Nato hat ihr größtes
Manöver seit Jahrzehnten angekündigt die
Übung mit rund 90.000 Soldaten soll im
Februar beginnen und den Ernstfall eines
russischen Angriffs auf das
bündnisgebiet Proben rund vier Monate
sind dafür angesetzt der Übung Raum
erstreckt sich von Norwegen im Norden
bis hin zu südlicheren Ländern wie
Rumänien Einschätzungen dazu und zur
Lage in der Ukraine von einem
Militärexperten um 19:30 Uhr bei ZDF
heute live zu sehen in unserer App und
auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen seit dem Überfall der
terroristischen Hamas im Oktober steht
die israelische Regierung doppelt unter
Druck die eigene Bevölkerung fordert
Sicherheit und dass sich das grausame
Morden nie wiederholt vielen im Ausland
dagegen geht Israels Kampf in Gaza zu
weit weil er auch Unschuldige trifft
beim weltwirtschaftstreffen in Davos
warb Israels Präsident Herzog jetzt
eindringlich um Verständnis Ulf
Röller ein Foto das Israels Trauer und
Wunden zeigt hat Präsident Herzog
mitgebracht die Welt soll sehen wie sein
Land
empfindet das ist kirbibas die
barbarischen Terroristen der Hamas haben
nicht nur ihn entführt sondern auch
seine Mutter seinen Bruder und seinen
Vater wir wissen sie gehen durch die
Hölle der Gazakrieg erschüttert den
ganzen Nahen Osten Israels
Militäroffensive fordert viele zivile
Opfer das Land steht in der Kritik wegen
der humanitären Katastrophe eine Frage
bewegt den Saal wie lange geht die
Militäroffensive noch und ist Israel
bereit Frieden zu verhandeln
niemand in Israel der bei klarem
Verstand ist ist bereit über einen
Frieden nachzudenken und wie eine
Vereinbarung aussehen könnte denn jeder
will nur wissen ob ihm wirkliche
Sicherheit in der Zukunft garantiert
werden
kann Iraks Premierminister ist nicht
gekommen um über Israels Sicherheit zu
sprechen sondern um Israel auf die
Anklagebank zu
setzen der Palästinenser nach einem
eigenen Staat wurde ignoriert das führte
zu den Ereignissen am 7 Oktober nun
haben wir einen dramatischen Krieg wir
erleben einen
Völkermord ob bibas noch lebt weiß
niemand so wie keiner in Davos auf die
Frage eine Antwort weiß wann der Krieg
endet im Mittleren Osten droht ein
Konflikt zwischen Iran und der Atommacht
Pakistan zu eskalieren pakistan hat am
Morgen Ziele im iranischen Grenzgebiet
beschießen lassen zehn Menschen wurden
getötet der Angriff war offenbar eine
Vergeltung weil Iran vorgestern
pakistanisches Grenzgebiet attakiert
hatte hintergrund ist die
Auseinandersetzung verschiedener
separatistengruppen in der Region nach
Hessen Boris rin ist dort alter und
neuer
Ministerpräsident der cdu-pitiker bekam
bei seiner Wiederwahl im Wiesbadener
Landtag eine Stimme mehr als seine neue
schwarzrote Koalition Mandate hat Boris
rin hatte seinen bisherigen
Koalitionspartner die Grünen nach der
Landtagswahl im vergangenen Oktober
gegen die SPD
ausgetauscht die öffentlichrechtlichen
Sender sollen effizienter und digitaler
werden so die Empfehlung des
zukunftsrats für ARD und ZDF
weitreichtenster Vorschlag um
mehrfachstrukturen abzubauen solle eine
neue ARD Anstalt die bisherige
Arbeitsgemeinschaft der verschiedenen
ardsender ersetzen aber auch das
stellten die unabhängigen Experten klar
zwei öffentlichrechtliche Anbieter seien
für ein großes Land wie Deutschland im
Interesse der Vielfalt auch in Zukunft
angemessen ZDF Intendant Himmler
begrüßte dass der Rat den Wert des
öffentlichrechtlichen Rundfunks für die
Gesellschaft und Demokratie betont
habe sind sie auch manchmal überrascht
wenn Ihnen Ihr Handy anzeigt wie viel
Zeit sie im Netz verbringen eine
digitalstudie der Postbank zeigt die
Nutzungsdauer hier zu Lande steigt
durchschnittlich
71 Stunden pro Woche verbringen Menschen
in Deutschland online das sind 6 Stunden
mehr als im Vorjahr bei den 18 bis
39jährigen sind es sogar 93 Stunden also
fast vier ganze Tage und das vor allem
mit dem Smartphone 84% der Befragten
nutzen das
Handy erst war es der Eisregen der in
der Mitte und im Süden Deutschlands
gestern für spiegelglatte Straßen sagte
dann kam viele Orts noch reichlich
Schnee dazu auf vielen Autobahnen ging
es nicht weiter vor allem wegen
querstehender LKW Kilometer lange Staus
Auto und Lastwagenfahrer mussten wie
hier auf der A3 von Hilfsorganisationen
versorgt werden einige stecken noch
immer fest Susanna Santina über die
aktuelle
Lage weiterhin keine Entwarnung für die
A5 zwischen Gießen und arsfeld seit fast
24 Stunden stauen sich hier immer wieder
vor allem dutzende LKW feuerwehrleute
hätten seit dem Nachmittag mit Brötchen
und warmen Getränken
aus das kommt auf jeden Fall gut die
waren schon mal hier und ist schon nett
von denen und super dass darum gehen das
Chaos begann letzte Nacht auf mehr als
50 km führte der intensive Schneefall
zum Stillstand viele Autobahnen konnten
nicht gestreut werden da vielfach auch
der Winterdienst festsß mehr LKW
blockierten die
Fahrstreifen ich habe noch Getränke
dabei vielleicht kann ich da noch ein
zwei Flaschen noch abgeben weil die tun
mir richtig gleich die pkwfahrer nichts
ging mehr auch auf der A3 von Loma bis
bi tonev 36 km Stau da konnte man
gefahrlos auf der Autobahn
stehen dieser Mann wollte dringend in
die Schweiz stundenlang musste er hier
ausharen mindestens 20 cm liegt der
Schnee der ist ja gar nicht geräumt und
dass man in Deutschland auch nicht
irgendwie mehr
streut hätte ich auch damit nicht
gerechnet 5 Stunden stehe ich hier und
tut sich nichts auf der A3 im
landkreiser schaffenburg kommt es am
Morgen zu einem schweren Unfall ein
Lkwfahrer prallt in die Seite eines
Sattelzugs und wird schwer verletzt und
im Nahverkehr gehen die Einschränkungen
auch heute
weiter ich wollte mit der Straßenbahn
fahren und hoffe ehrlich gesagt dass ich
jetzt mit der deutschen mal wenigstens
vorankomme ja immer noch finde ich kein
Bus ich habe keine Ahnung wie ich jetzt
fahren soll bis in die Nacht muss mit
Verkehrsbehinderungen gerechnet werden
nicht nur auf den Straßen trotz der
permanenten enteisungen fallen am
Frankfurter Flughafen heute viele Flüge
aus in 75 Minuten ist es soweit anwurf
in Köln das erste em Hauptrundenspiel
des DHB Teams gegen Island ja das ist ja
das Heimatland vom bundest Trainer
Alfred geslerson der dürfte also gleich
zwei nationalhümnen anstimmen Island
startet genau wie Deutschland mit null
Punkten in die Hauptrunde ja Jörg Polus
in Köln klare Sache ein deutscher Sieg
ist
Pflicht ja Norbert absolut wobei man
sagen muss dass das heutige Spiel dann
doch nur der Auftakt sein kann denn wenn
die Mannschaft den Traum vom Halbfinale
weiter treuen möchte dann muss
eigentlich jedes der vier Spiele in der
Hauptrunde gewonnen werden und so ist es
vielleicht sogar verständlich dass die
Spiel ein bisschen angespannter wirkten
als üblich als Sie heute hier in Köln an
der Halle angekommen sind in jeden Fall
aber volle Konzentration auf den Gegner
auf Island und vielleicht ist Island
dann auch der richtige erst Gegner in
dieser Hauptrunde denn Isländer haben
durchaus Schwächen in der Vorrunde
gezeigt und diese Schwächen die kennt
der Isländisch deutsche Bundestrainer
Alfred gislerson aber ganz sicher
bestens übrigens ebenso wie die Stärken
um 20:15 Uhr geht's los hier in Köln
dann bis
gleich zum biatlon Weltcup in anholz da
ist Johannes kühn im 15 km Einzel
Dritter geworden beim letzten Anschlag
leistete er sich seine beiden einzigen
Schießfehler sonst wäre wohl noch mehr
drin gewesen für den Passauer Platz 1
und 2 ging an die norwegischen Brüder
Johannes Dinges und tagal
Böh Deutschlands erfolgreichster weltcut
Abfahrer Thomas Dresen beendet seine
aktive Skikarriere am Samstag beim renn
in kitsbül er sei der körperlichen
Belastung nicht mehr gewachsen Dresen
kämpft seit Jahren mit
Knieproblemen die Deutschen hockeyfrauen
haben das Ticket für Paris gelöst nach
einem dramatischen Halbfinalsieg im
Olympia Qualifikationsturnier gegen
Gastgeber Indien mit 4:3 nach penetle
schießen ja und bei den Australian Open
sind Tatjana Maria und Jan lenuf
ausgeschieden Alexander s dagegen gewann
in einem hartumkämpften Match gegen den
slowakischen Qualifikanten Lukas klein
in fünf Sätzen nach 4 Stunden und 31
Minuten im tibck und trifft in Runde 3
am Samstag auf den US-Amerikaner Alex
Mickelson wäre übgens der letzte
deutsche einzelspielende melbn ja
hoffentlich bleibt er noch ein bisschen
ne h ein bisschen Schnee ist noch
angesagt aber es wird ruhiger und
sonniger sagt östen terli gleich etwas
detaillierter das heute Journal mit
Dunja Hayali in der handballhalbzeit
kurz nach
und wir freuen uns wenn Sie Lust haben
morgen wieder dabei zu sein danke Ihnen
alles Gute einen schönen Abend noch und
auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter ja der
Schnee im Süden ver abschiedet sich
allmählich und wird weniger denn das
Hoch hier vom Atlantik her dehnt es sich
aus und wird relativ breit und
umfangreich und so gibt es relativ viel
Sonnenschein in der Nacht im Süden also
noch Schneefälle natürlich ist hier auch
Glätter angesagt so wie im restlichen
Land denn Schnee und Eis sind ja immer
noch ein Thema ganz im Norden ziehen
Schneeschauer durch in der Mitte kann es
auch mal neblig werden Temperaturen dazu
-10° hier Richtung vogland und 1° Plus
an der Nordsee morgen dann im Süden noch
letzte Schneefälle dann lässt es hier
nach ganz im Norden ziehen Schauer und
auch Gewitter durch mit Schneefall
ansonsten dazwischen häufig Sonnenschein
auch mal kompaktere Wolken es bleibt
aber überwiegend trocken Temperaturen
dazu maximal Werte mit -3° hier nach
Osten hin und 5° plus Richtung Nordsee
ja das Wochenende das wird relativ
sonnig werden am Samstag vor allem im
Süden im Norden ziehen weiteren
Schneeschauer durch -2 bis 5° und Montag
erwartet uns ein Wetterwechsel der es in
sich hat ein Sturm zieht auf einen
schönen Abend